[inaudible]
joining me today as an activist and
advocate who cofounded the student led gun
control advocacy group.
Never again MSD.
He also helped organize the march for
our lives nationwide student protest
earlier this year. Cameron Caskey
welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me. I'm really happy
that you're here for for many reasons.
Uh,
mostly because you strike me suddenly
as someone that's trying to find some
common ground these days and we're gonna
get into that in a whole bunch more.
But uh,
of course I have to mention up top,
you are a survivor of the
parkland shooting in Florida. Um,
before we go all into that and everything
that you've been through since,
just tell me a little
bit about life before,
cause I assume you have a life
before and now a new life.
Yes.
Well,
you know,
I spent most of my life as your typical
little shitster who just said whatever
you wanted to have a voice.
I was always still convinced that
I was right about everything,
whether that was nature and nurture
is kind of up to interpretation,
but I really grew up just dead set
on the fact that I knew everything.
Everything I said was right and I was a
genius. I learned the hard way recently,
little too recently that I'm not,
and that was a crazy awakening.
Learning that you don't know everything
in the entire world is actually an
interesting experience.
But one of the things that helped
me a lot was doing theater.
I was a big theater kid
because I had this voice.
I always wanted to express
myself. I was, uh, you know,
I was flippantly loud all the time and do,
I didn't know what to do with it.
You know, I was knocking doors for
Obama when I was seven. Hmm. Wow. Yeah,
I was really interested in, you know,
being active with all that. I mean,
I knew nothing. I thought that John
Mccain was running with Tina Fey,
not Sarah Pailin,
because I had really only seen the
news and I guess I got it mixed up.
I was seven. Yeah, I didn't expect
myself to be a policy expert,
but you know, again, I,
I think the point is I was
always really excited to,
to speak and I, and I got involved
with drama and drama. Said, hey,
you have a voice,
here's where to use it.
And you learn a lot of lessons
from doing theater. Have you,
have you ever done anything
stay back at school?
Not In high school.
I did spend 12 years doing
standup comedy in New York City,
which is a whole other nightmare.
But yeah,
I um,
I was wanting to do stand up and then I
tried it once when I was seven years old.
I was on a cruise with my family and
there was a kind of adults only nightclub.
It wasn't really, you are able
to get in if you were younger,
but I was the only person
there under maybe 40.
And they had an open mic and I kept on,
I kept on raising my hand to get
on and the host was saying, no,
what the hell is this kid doing?
And finally he just caved in and was like,
all right, let's let the
kid get up here. And,
and I walk up there and I
drop a three minute routine.
I make a joke about my dad's penis. Uh,
which was an interesting experience.
And the thing is, I did not
know that while I was sitting
alone in the front row,
I snuck out of my room, my parents to
the club and I didn't see them. Wow.
So I'm out. I'm out there, I'll say, I'll
send you the kit, the clip privately.
I'm out there and I'm four foot three and,
and everybody's drunk. So they think
I'm a riot. So I think I'm a riot.
And I just kept going and going to the
point where the guy who was running the
open mic was just looming behind
me waiting for me to be done.
But I guess he just didn't want to grab
the Mike from a small child without
looking kind of weird.
Stand up is probably best done once at
seven years old and never again to hear
exactly what you're doing.
Everybody's had their 15 minutes of fame
when they were seven on a cruise. Yeah.
All right. So, so you
were a theater kid. Um,
anything else we should know about?
Just like high school life,
like high school life for sure. A kid
in 2017, 2018 like, what's it like? I'm,
I'm not that old, but I ain't
17 anymore. Well, you know, I,
high school was really fun for me.
I really enjoyed it on a social level.
I was a shitty student on my
test scores were always good,
but my grades were awful because
they never bothered to do homework.
I thought I was too smart
and cool for that. But, um,
I liked high school a lot because I,
I never really subscribed
to one social circle.
I kind of hung out with a lot of people,
you know,
kids who were the stereotypical
popular you kids, you know,
I was just the guy they
knew that was funny.
I would hang out with them sometimes
kids who were that stereotypical nerds,
we would talk about
movies and comic books,
which I want to get into your
comic book collection. Um, and I,
I'd say that my core group
was the theater kids.
I love my friends from drama and um,
it's really fun having a
group of friends where you'll,
you'll be hanging out in the weekend
shooting the Shit and then you'll get to
school and either be falling in love with
each other and making out on stage or
killing each other on stage.
You know,
we just did fiddler on the roof and I
got to marry one of my best friends.
It was really fun.
I'm sure you're familiar.
Fiddler I am familiar with the
lyrics is a classic, so. All right,
so it sounds like a pretty
normal childhood then so far,
I don't think someone like me can
be traded by normal childhood,
but it was a great childhood.
I'm very happy.
My parents divorced when I was 10 and
I'm lucky enough to have four grade
parents. You know, I've got two brothers
and a step sister. It's a great group.
When I'd like to think that I'm a pretty
moral guy and when I'm the shittiest
person in a family, it's a great family.
So you have a standup comic in you.
I can see it. Hopefully it doesn't
come out anytime soon. All right.
So now bring me to that
day shorter this year.
So on February 14th, there
was a, it was a regular day.
It was actually a really nice day and
there was a period of time during the day
that I always remember where I thought
that he's going a little too well. Hmm.
I was sitting reading John Walsh's book,
uh,
tears of rage I believe if
you're familiar. I don't
remember the title exactly,
but I was a big fan and um,
and I was planning out a Valentine's Day
gift for a girl that I really liked. Uh,
she had, uh, she had an
endoscopy that day and she was,
she was on a lot of medicine and I was
going to give her cousins some gifts for
her and have her bring it to her and I
made her a card that said I would have
brought you this myself, but I didn't
have the stomach for it dry. I printed a,
figured had a picture of her doctor
and put it in the card and everything.
And then I'm, we're in rehearsal for a
musical. We were doing, he'll vikings,
which I'm sure nobody's ever heard
of. I don't know it. And uh, I was,
we had just finished up a song and I was
doing, and I realized, wait a second,
I have to go pick up my brother because
that's still my Douglas school lets out
at two 40,
but the special needs kids are out at
two 10 so the parents can pick them up
before the buses come.
And my little brother has autism and
he's hanging out there with all of his
friends and the Ese class.
And by the way,
the autistics seen had Stoneman Douglas
is awesome. Those kids are the best.
And um,
this is a school specialized in that.
Is it like a magnet school
for kids with autism or no,
but it has a great program
with great teachers.
And I actually went back to Parklin this
weekend to see them off to homecoming.
And boy, let me tell you that squad as
wild I of them. And um, my little brother,
I don't want to brag, is kind of
the ring leader over there. Um, and,
and I went to go pick them up because on
days like that when my mom was at work,
I would take him to drama
and he would just hang out.
And he really loved it because all
the girls would give them attention.
And you know, he's, he's a bit
of a cocky little bastard. And,
um, I realized that it's
maybe to 20, let's say,
and we're halfway through the song and
I say, I forgot to pick up, hold it.
So we finished the song and I asked my
teacher if I could go run and pick them
up.
Of course she said yes,
and I'm picking up Holden and
suddenly there's a fire alarm. And I,
and that was a little scary because we
were close to pick up and I was with the
special needs kids. Some of them were in
wheelchairs, some of whom were not, were,
you know,
a little physically disabled.
And we had to go to the parking lot where
the buses would come. And I said, oh no,
what if this,
what if this is a real fire and I have
to sit out here and make sure that nobody
gets hit by a bus. There were teachers
there of course, but you know,
it's a public school.
There maybe two teachers for 10 15
students who won't need a lot of help.
Sure.
So we're out there sitting in the parking
lot and were there were students out
there from other classes nearby who
uh, cause again, this is a fire drill.
There were students out there who
were with us and it was the Ese class.
It was a couple of the nearby classes.
And one of the kids jokingly
said as a shooter, I said, Dude,
shut the fuck up. That's not cool because
how could that ever happen? Right.
And suddenly I see everybody running
back and side and the teacher says get
inside, get inside. And I said,
oh, okay. It wasn't a real fire.
And they want to get all the kids
inside before the buses come.
And then we're told to go in
a room and were told to hide,
get away from the window and turn
the lights off. And I say, okay,
something's going on.
And that experience was,
was an interesting one because I was in
the leadership room with a lot of the
leadership students,
which is a class that specializes
in leadership and they plan prom and
everything sort of student government.
And it was also the special needs kids
because it was the nearest room and some
of the students being nonverbal.
Does that mean you can't make noise?
And some of the students
were yelling and wailing.
Fortunately they had shadows and the
special needs teachers at Douglas are
fantastic and we're able
to keep everybody calm,
but we didn't know what was going on.
And we were there for a couple hours
and slowly more details begin to emerge.
And I assume you're hearing gunfire
and no, no. Douglas is a huge school.
And I wasn't. Now mind you, I thought
I heard gunfire, but when you're told,
being told you're school is getting
shot up and you hear anything,
you might think it's gunfire. Yeah,
but I'm sitting there holding,
my little brother has no
idea what's going on and,
and slowly I realized,
okay,
there's a shooting I heard and people
were whispering around the room.
It was maybe 20 kids in the room,
people saying 50 people are dead,
two people are dead. One
person, his dad, Eh, eh.
There were conflicting stories. I heard
conflicting stories of who was the chef,
who the shooter was.
I heard five different names,
one of whom was somebody I knew.
Somebody I knew would not pick up a
weapon to harm of butterfly because that's
hysteria and that and that's
natural and I understand it.
Then I saw something that was a terrible
exhibit of humanity. If you ask me,
which was there was a snapchat video going
around that was that with the caption
Yo with multiple owes my school getting
shot up and it was a video of a dead
teacher. Look, if you're going to film as,
as shooting from inside a room so you
can have evidence to show the police,
good on you. If you're going to
fill my shooting in a room and say,
Yo my school getting shot up and
send it to everybody, you know,
that's pretty awesome.
Yeah.
And when you're sitting there in a room
not knowing what's going on and you see
videos of people you know
and love deceased and the,
and the only video I saw was,
or somebody who had,
I had cared about for many years,
he was a mentor in my life.
You start to realize that nothing is ever
going to be the same again. Yeah. Yeah.
Wait,
let's pause for one sec cause that we
shouldn't gloss over that part where the
social media component of this is so
important because you guys all grew up on
this and then you grow up hearing
about school shootings all the time.
And I could see, I don't know who
this kid is. It doesn't matter.
I'm sure I'm periods perfectly fine person
or he or she. But it's like, you know,
doing that, it's like, it
just, it almost feels like,
oh that's the normal thing to do.
Like there's a shooting like
[inaudible] on snapchat, you know,
several people I knew were
just treating it. Yeah.
Like it was normal. I mean
not the shooting, but the
fact that there was a video.
And so I understand how some people
might like to not like, but you know,
understand having to see that because
they need to understand what's going on.
But I saw it and I said,
how could you do that?
This is somebody who is deceased
and you're filming them to show,
to send it to all your friends.
And that's a reflection of
the social media era we're in,
where everything that's going on,
you got to show everyone.
So for how long were you
actually in that room?
Not knowing if you were going to be okay,
not knowing what was happening.
I think it was about two hours.
Um, I could look at interviews.
I did days after and have a much
better gauge. I forget. Yeah.
But I would call it around two hours.
And you know when the Swat
team broke the door down,
there was the big issue that there are
students who are developmentally disabled
in here who might not be
able to put their hands up.
And fortunately one of the only good
things you'll see from Broward [inaudible]
handling of the shooting was the swat
team was very understanding and was very
quick to help these students, which
was good. But when that glass broken,
the first thing that walked
into a room was a was a rifle.
How are we supposed to know that?
That wasn't us taking our term but and I,
everybody was texting their parents.
Everybody at the phone lines were kind
of jammed cause everybody in Parkland was
making a call. I mean it was
Parkland. It was a city with,
I don't even know how many people,
but it's small town where
there's one high school.
Is there one high school?
There's just around
one high school and we,
I mean nobody should be equipped
for this, but we weren't. Yeah.
Had you guys been taught at all?
Like are they teaching in high school?
Like what to do if this actually
does happen. If a shooter sure.
Comes through school. We had the
discussion of having a code red drill.
We had had long discussions
about dealing with a shooter,
but we had never participated
in and code red drill.
I at least not while I was at school.
I used to skip school a lot. Yeah.
Tell me a little bit more
about the makeup of Parkland.
Cause you mentioned something interesting
that it's kind of like a little
liberal [inaudible] Markland
at a pretty liberal area.
It's not homogeneous when it
comes to being liberal. You know,
there's a lot of different perspectives,
but the majority of people in Parkland
are pretty liberal and pretty classic
liberal.
And um,
and that's why you'll see a lot of
the activism to come out of Stoneman.
Douglas was less, you know,
let's, let's, I don't know,
it was very gun control
related. Yeah. So let's, we'll,
we'll get to that in a little bit because
obviously so much has happened in the
spotlight that has been put on
you guys and everything else and,
and several of you have stepped into it.
And I think there's,
there's probably good parts
of that in bad parts of that.
I think that's probably why you're here
right now. Double edged sword. Yeah. Um,
okay. So it ends now what are,
you know, they tell you all right.
You can walk out of this room. I mean
sure. I can't imagine. So we ran,
we ran with our hands up. We
sat outside for a bit. Um,
I was able to go on a city bus with my
little brother's class to the Marriott,
which is the hotel,
the only hotel in Parkland.
And so they weren't letting parents come.
No parents were coming to
pick us up at the hotel.
But there were a lot of different
ways students got out of the school,
a lot of different places. They
went, some kids I know just ran. Um,
which is understandable. Normally when
there's a mass shooting nearby you run.
And,
um,
my brother and I were at the Marriott
Hotel and our father picked us up,
took us over an hour to get home
because as I'm sure you can understand,
the streets were very jammed.
I mean after the shooting,
Parkland was a no man's land.
It,
this wasn't mad max anarchy where
everybody was wearing leather spikes,
but it was a no man's land.
There was,
it was as if time and space had been
the rules of physics and matter didn't
really exist. It was
eerie. It was seven days,
at least for me.
That was when that period of really
surreal fear with existed that,
that nothing felt real. And um,
then they can't, news was there,
there wasn't the most we got was somebody
at the sunset and we'll talking about
our production of fiddler
on the roof. The, um,
did you in that period, and I'm sure it's
very hard to even remember it clearly.
Did you have a real chance
to mourn, to figure out what
happened? Um, I don't know.
You can maybe let me know how close
you were to maybe some of the students
because it seems like,
and I think this was part of the problem
with the way we deal with these things,
is that we go from the incident to
immediately a special on social media just
attacking each other and
destroying each other.
Then you guys all get thrust into
the spotlight and it's like, Whoa,
this would be hard on, on an adult,
you know, impossibly hard. Meanwhile,
you have these kids who are now out
there talking about these things.
These kids need to mourn.
I mean need to figure out what's going
on with life and find some reality in
decency.
So I,
I think that there's really no formula
for recovering for from a mass shooting,
especially when at a school,
I mean,
enough of happened that they're
starting to develop a precedence,
which is a horrible thing, but there's
really nowhere to look. You can,
I could have hidden away,
I could have locked myself in my room
for weeks and maybe that would have been
the right thing to do. I could
have. I didn't know what to do.
And my way of coping has
always been doing something.
I had dealt with some tragic loss
this past year and I had the,
there were some really dark things
that happened to people that I loved.
And the way I always handled
them was by doing something.
I never liked to have a
clear head because, well,
I think it's important to process
your pain and deal with it.
I also think that the, if I, if something
like that happens and I do nothing,
I'm never going to forget myself.
I had survivor guilt. Why?
Why should I have left that day?
There were 15 year old girls that
were murdered and I made it out.
And if I could have pressed a
button to trade my life for theirs,
it wouldn't have even been, hmm. Well
maybe I should say goodbye to people.
Maybe I should think about this.
No,
I would have broken my
finger pressing it too hard.
So what made me deserve life when
other people who did nothing wrong.
If people more innocent, more kind
than I am, didn't get to make it out.
And I realized while I'm alive and,
and one of my mentors wasn't Scott Eagle
and one of the nicest guys I've ever
met. He's the reason that I'm a snarky
little asshole. I developed that from him.
Um,
he didn't make it out there and he's
somebody who changed young people's lives
by making them better and making
them more proud of themselves. So,
so what makes me, what has
me deserving of this? No,
I'm not a very religious or
spiritual person, so I don't,
I didn't think there was some great
plan that got me out of school,
but I think that I had a responsibility
at a responsibility to do right by the
people we lost and to do what I thought
would make the world a better place
while they can't, because there
were marriages that didn't happen.
There were people who
would have had children and
the didn't get, I don't know,
it's a horrible thing to think.
But at the end of the day, uh,
lives ended and I still had mine.
So I said after the shooting when
I'm going to do is something,
and I, I was uh, you know,
I've been a big liberal most of my life
and I s and I've always been an advocate
for gun control.
I was a big debater of other students
after the shooting in Las Vegas where I
said nobody needs these were,
we're in a point in our society where
we're advanced enough that nobody needs an
assault weapon to take care of themselves.
Look at the,
look at the way these guns are made.
We can defend ourselves at handguns and
my father has multiple in the house.
He's a reserve police officer. He was
Miami shores for awhile. I didn't,
I instantly said the thing we can do here,
let's stop folks like the shooter at
my school from getting these weapons
because this is a 19 year old who
if he had spent five minutes with a
psychologist would have been sent
to a therapist and not a gun store.
Yeah. Okay. So let's, before
we get specifically to far
down the, the gun road here,
which obviously we're going to touch
on. Okay. You guys are trying to mourn,
you know,
you're having survivor guilt,
all of these things I'm sure just in your
family and your brother and everything
else. Just, I can't even imagine then
the media because I think this is,
we have to hit media stuff before we
get to the gun. The media then descend.
What was that like?
I mean,
I assume everybody and their brother was
trying to reach out to all of you guys.
They were putting you guys on TV. I
mean, I probably even that very day.
Um, what was that like
for you guys or for you?
I, you know, the whole, our
whole situation with the media,
whether it be anything from CNN to Fox
News to Ellen was a double edged sword
because on the one,
on the one hand,
there are bodies that are
warm and right here on TV.
And in retrospect I might have done
that differently. I'm not sure.
On the other hand, I couldn't let
this be like Sandy Hook for example.
I couldn't let this be people coming in
to film crying mothers talking about how
bad these guns are and leave. I wanted
to get out there and say, no, okay, this,
how many of these do we need
before we do some that I don't,
I didn't want people to see Parkland as
a place where everybody was crying and
everybody was throwing a pity party.
I wanted to people to see Parkland as a
place where a terrible tragedy happened
and this city is stood up and said,
no,
we're not going to be like these other
places. We are going to be a catalyst.
I mean, before, before
Stoneman Douglas, I would send,
I would hear the word sandy hook in a
room and everybody would get quiet and it
would be weird. I couldn't have
that be Stoneman Douglas this place.
That was my school. I loved my school.
I was a big school spirit fellow.
It was about to become a statistic.
It was about to become that one dark
thing that somebody will make a joke about
or somebody will say something
bad about or really anything.
So I got out there and said, no. And
so many people got out there and said,
this cannot be another
example of everybody. Luton.
Everybody crying. Yeah.
We're not here to cry.
We're here to tell you what we can
do to make this a better world.
Were there people, I assume
parents, advisors, whoever,
that were kind of guiding you
through the media part of this?
Because there were so many strange moments
where it seemed like, okay, I said,
do you right before, I don't want to
make this about any specific student,
especially in, I don't want to
throw anyone out on the bus.
But when we'd see someone like David Hogg
who obviously is very public now, uh,
you know, saying things that
didn't quite seem right or,
or talking about laws and all this stuff,
like going from just surviving to
suddenly advocacy with almost no space in
between. Uh, you know,
well,
I think the general idea is I think the
general idea of going right to advocacy,
while it might not have been our best
call to immediately go to it was these
cameras are only here for so long
and we couldn't have them leave.
There's that double edged
sword. Exactly. Yeah. So do we,
do we wait our respectful time and then
go out and advocate or what people not
care. And I think I stand by advocacy.
I'm not sure. I think on a moral
level I might not, but on a,
but generally I think that while everybody
was looking we had to say, let's,
let's look at what we really
want to look at here. Yeah.
These are like give these
families their space.
Were, were any of you guys afraid that
you were being looked at as experts?
Suddenly where as horrific as what
happened to you was it doesn't make you an
expert either in law or in
guns or any of those things.
Like you can very eloquently as you're
doing right now, tell me your story.
Tell me what you think. All of those
things. But especially at the beginning,
I'm sure you know way more now.
You don't know everything.
Nobody knows everything.
And they were throwing a bunch of 17 year
olds out there as if they were experts
on all of these things. And I think
that also added to some of the,
the tumbled around everything.
Well at the time it was awesome.
Yeah. I mean, I was an expert. I felt,
I felt phenomenal. I was somebody
that everybody was looking to as if I,
as if I knew everything. And as I said
before, that was what I wanted. Yeah. And,
and it wasn't a good feeling.
I, I'll be honest with you,
some things about it felt good and
most of it felt like a terrible,
interesting. You just said it's
awesome and it wasn't a good feeling.
That's probably sums it up,
I guess.
Yeah,
it was awesome to me that I got to the,
I spent my whole life watching people
talk about laws and watching people talk
about politics. And now I got to say
this and my word got to be respected,
but every time I went out there I
thought there are people dead. And it's,
it's just, it's a, it's a, it's
a moral qualm. Am I out here at,
I'm doing this because I believe in it
and I'm doing this because I don't want
the world to lose people again, nobody
deserves to be shot. Nobody at all.
Nobody who's a good person
deserves to be shot. So,
so I, it was, it was difficult
for me because on the one hand,
it was this amazing feeling of,
here's my voice.
Everybody's listening.
Let me tell you what you all need to hear.
And what everybody need to hear was we
need to pass gun laws. It's been enough.
If people did nothing after Columbine,
I would have understood because
that was supposed to be an anomaly.
I'm sure you remembered.
That was of course a shocker.
And then Stoneman Douglas happened and
it was more of an another, not a woe.
So, so it felt, it felt great
that people were carrying,
that was the,
that was what I would say it was the
awesome part was that I was afraid
everybody would,
everybody in the country would
feel helpless and cry and be done.
But it was amazing to see
that the country was saying,
maybe there's something we can do here,
maybe we can make some change.
And the thing that was awful was I was,
I was going from news hits to,
to memorial services.
Yeah. So you've had a sort of
interesting evolution about all this and,
and it sort of leads to where we're going
to end, which is what you're doing now,
which is pretty awesome. Um, so
all right, you're part of the,
now you're part of the media machine.
You guys are trying to
figure out what can you do?
I assume that's sort of how march for
our life started and if I'm not mistaken,
it started doing here.
That's right. Start it in
my bathroom. Yeah, I was um,
I was coming out of the showers and
putting on my Ghostbusters Pj's,
it was a slimer. It wasn't
old school. Ghostbusters. Yes,
of course. Of course. Right.
I um, we could talk about the new
Ghostbusters maybe after this part.
How much hate do you want to get online?
I look,
I'll tell you this, everybody in
that cast is incredibly talented.
I didn't like the movie very much,
but there's really nobody who
is in it that I think was not,
is not an incredibly funny person.
But anyway, I, I'm excited.
One of my home and I got a lot
of my friends together. Some,
I called everyone who I knew
was intelligent and well
spoken and was willing to
put their time to grieve aside to
demand action because it's, you know,
I felt like it was in some ways public
service because people are grieving and
we're out here saying,
we're gonna put that aside as,
as much as I wanted to cry every day
and mind you, I really want to do.
And I did a lot. I knew that I had to
put that aside. I had to do something.
So I got everybody that I knew could
do something to mostly my drama friends
cause I knew that they could speak and
we all got together at my house and said,
well,
what do we do with this whole,
this whole country people on both
sides or all morning together?
How can we get everybody on both sides
together to do something? Now mind you,
that didn't happen. Getting people on
both sides didn't really happen. Yeah. Um,
that can be a tough one.
It's,
and it is a tough one and then
it will always be a tough one,
but it's something that needs
to be done. And, and you know,
from, from my home, we were
sleeping two hours a night.
I would go entire days only eating one
protein bar, not even realizing we were.
So it was such a tornado that we were all,
we all kind of forgot what it
was like to a normal person.
So you come up with the idea
for March for our lives,
now get us to that day.
And what was it supposed to be?
What,
what were the actual original intentions
beyond, let's not forget about this.
Original intentions were let's get gun
control passed and I'm still a big,
let's get gun control past guy.
And um,
and that's what we wanted to do.
We want to say everybody out here saying,
we should do this. Let's get
everyone together. Let's,
let's get a big march
together where people say,
I want,
I'm coming all the way out here.
I'm standing out here
today to demand this. And,
and seeing everybody together
was amazing. I, um, you get it.
Getting up on the stage and
seeing all those people,
I didn't care about the being in front
of him. I mean, I was a drama kid. Uh,
I stood in front of people and
taught for the past five years,
but I saw all those people and I said,
these people believe in something.
These people come from different places.
These people that are
all completely different,
but they're all together
cause they believe in one
thing. And that was magical.
And I don't use the word magical
very often. I think it's Cliche,
but that was magical. And it was,
it was, it was amazing to see.
But from the beginning of
our ad advocacy to the march,
it was,
it was a lot of personalities together
and we were able to make it through the
pain we felt together. I mean,
so often people said, well,
why are you guys at your
school got shot up a month ago.
Your school got shot up three weeks ago.
Why are you smiling? And I said, well,
I,
at least from my own personal perspective,
the teacher that I was dear friends with,
that I lost Scotland want me to cry.
Scott would want me to do something.
Scott would want me to do what I believed
in. He wasn't a very political guy,
he will, after the shooting, he probably
wouldn't have focused on any politics.
He would have focused on getting everybody
at Douglas to feel better, to laugh,
to smile. But if I believed in something
and I wanted to advocate for it,
I knew that if he were here, he'd say,
well, go do it. So the time I spent,
I was sitting at his memorial and
I was crying and I was in the dirt.
I was all snotty. I, I tried to wipe
my face and my dirty hands and I,
it was what many would consider the low
point in the movie when the person feels
like they've lost everything.
And then I thought about it and if
Scott Yoda to behind me as a ghost,
which he and I used to talk
about actually, and I used
to talk about Yoda in, um,
if he ordered behind me and he would say,
Cameron,
do something. You must, he used to talk
to me in your voice a lot and not go,
we were going to go your Yoda impression
there, and it's not gonna happen. Um,
somebody else had the
exclusive on that one? No.
There were points where
Scott was my teacher in fifth
grade and he owed voice to
me while I was asking him
a genuine question, which
frustrated me a lot button.
It's for another time.
I could do a three hour interview on him,
but he would have said, do something.
So, so when we were all smiling together,
when we were all laughing together,
it was because I knew that somebody
that I loved would've wanted me to,
and we had each other.
That's the thing. If I were,
if I was advocating for gun control alone,
it wouldn't have worked.
Not only because I couldn't
have done it alone.
I'm not good enough to do it alone,
but also because we were each
other's lifeline when I was, when,
when everything seemed awful
and everything seemed like
the world was this dark,
terrible place. I had my friends
around me to say, we got,
we're here for you. We've got this
together. And I was, you know,
some people shoulder, many people were my
shoulder. I'm more emotional than many.
I'm a theater students.
So more people had to help me that I need
to help them and beyond the emotional
part and getting everybody together.
And as you said,
you're still a gun control
advocate and all that.
I sent that part of what happened around
March for our lives was you saw things
getting bizarrely political or or more
than what perhaps you are you guys
wanted. Is that fair to say?
I think what marsh fair lives
should have you see to political issue.
I think the way it should have come off,
and I think this is what everybody I
worked with believes I know for a fact is
that our kids would want to get shot.
That's what we are at the end of the day.
We are kids who are out here
saying we don't want to die.
And back then I thought that if you
didn't believe in my gun control beliefs,
you didn't care if kids died.
I learned that that's not the case.
But that's a pretty interesting evolution
for someone at 17 to have within,
you know,
five or six months.
I spoke to people who disagree with me
and I learned that they want the country
to be a better place. You know, that we
might not agree on how we might think,
I might think that their views
are horse shit, but every,
we all agree on basically 90% of
things and I'm sure there are plenty of
political things you and I will
disagree on, but at the end of the day,
Tom Mcfarland is one of the most gifted
Spiderman writers to agree on that.
Do you ever do anything with DC?
I'm more of a marvel guy,
but I had a pretty good
Batman collection for awhile.
Nightwing is my favorite superhero.
If you're familiar as you think
they think in comic books,
they're very afraid to make real change
and Nightwing actually was able to make
it through that. You know, if, uh,
if a Robin became his own superhero,
normally that would only be for
10 issues and then he'd go back.
But now you actually made that jump.
I encourage you all to read
going back and we can focus on McFarland,
Spiderman from to 98 to three 35
that the idea of venom is brilliant.
But I saw the movie trailer for the movie.
We'll talk about that off camera. Um,
that sounds good. Tom Hardy's
gifted. So, so the way,
the way people should have seen us in
the way I failed really in the messaging
because I was so deeply involved with it,
was we just don't want to get killed and
quickly because of the perfect storm of
everything,
it became left versus right and,
and I don't think anybody
in my group wanted that.
I don't think anybody in my group wants
that at all. But it's, in one way,
the media is the media's portrayal.
It's in one way my personal inability to
express it correctly. And another way,
my arrogance, because I was pretty
arrogant. I mean that in a way,
I mean that from the bottom of my heart.
I mean everybody else.
I worked with a march for our lives was a,
a kid who wanted to help the world,
but I was a cocky little son of a bitch.
And that,
and that translated a lot because I said
I'm right. That's the thing. I'm right.
Everything I say about gun control is
completely right. So, so why? Why don't,
why aren't you listening to me?
Because I'm obviously in the right here.
Everybody else, again, was, was
basically saying, I don't want to die.
Here's how I think it could work.
But I said, I'm right politically.
This is my political movement.
Listened to my politics.
That's my fault. And that's
okay. I'm blaming myself.
I was a kid who lost friends and I
thought that this is what we needed and I
still do, but my, my big error, my what?
What's the, what's the word from a tragic
year? That's their flaw. Hamartia. Hubris.
Well, this is your Hubris,
I suppose. Yeah. That, let's
call it the Hebrew. So again,
I didn't take AP Lang or AP lit.
I can tell you my favorite tragic heroes.
I love tragic heroes. But
my hubris was, and again,
I could be interpreting this wrong,
I just thought I was right.
I thought that anybody who didn't
agree with me because I was so right,
we wanted kids to die. 1% of the, no,
I wouldn't say that.
My guess is that 3% of the country
doesn't care when kids die.
3% just as not my kid or you know,
it's not where I am,
but the rest of the country doesn't
want kids to die. And you know,
I learned about that,
that family in Texas where the mom and
the dad both carry weapons because they
want to protect their family.
I learned about the people in everywhere
who want to protect their families.
I have guns in my house and while I
believe in an assault weapons ban,
or at least much more restrictive laws,
if you want to hurt my autistic brother
and I have a gun, you're in trouble.
So when you see
someone like David Hogg and
I'm only mentioning because
he's been so vocal on or
you know, I tried to talk
about ideas and not people,
but when you see someone like him tweeting
all of these things, but you know,
I don't want to get an exact quote
crossed up here, but to the effect,
if you don't agree with me, you want
dead kids. Republicans want dead kids.
Marco Rubio doesn't want to save anybody.
While all of these things you now
realize that's just not the way to do it.
That is not true and it's not.
It's not actually effective.
The reason I criticize myself and
not my friends, because I know David,
David is a dear friend of mine.
I've known him for a couple of years,
but I've only known him really well since
the shooting in a class with him once.
He was nice guy. Everything David does,
and I know we're not talking specifics,
but I'll just use David as an example
because much like everybody else in March
for our lives,
everything David does,
he does because he wants the
country to be a better place.
He and I don't always see perfectly
eye to eye on what exactly to do,
but every time I something he tweets
that I don't like and uh, I love,
I think about it and I say I've
spent hours of David, I've known him,
I know him so incredibly well
because we have this dark, tragic,
terrible bond that was really created
after the worst case scenario.
But when David says something
that I don't agree with,
he's saying it because he doesn't
want another kid to die. So you know,
messaging with everybody in the group
is occasionally not really in sync.
We agree.
We disagree on things sometimes.
But if I thought that people in March
for our lives like David or anyone was in
this for the wrong reasons,
I would be [inaudible] I
would instantly call them out.
I don't think that's the case.
Yeah.
Unfortunately the road to hell is paved
with good intentions and I don't want to
smirch his intentions.
I believe you.
I believe you that his intentions are
pure. I, of course, I believe that David,
David's a guy who cares so deeply
about the world around him,
and we'll do whatever it takes
to make it a better place.
But it's funny that you say the road
to hell is paved with good intentions
because our summer tour where we went
around and advocating for more voter
registration and more accessible voting
around the country was called road to
change.
And there was a counter protest,
or at one of our events that said more
like the road to hell. And I said, hey,
that's not very nice.
[inaudible].